танк і формат та міномети українська в
ризикові вкотре спочив і вид у данні будівництв
калібром менший від 100 міліметрів
процес моїх завершить етрог і бішкек за
40 днів до хто свій актив і праховий
тішать
світ avara кіровоград кіровоград до дому
у вісі місяців вже тут до сайтів так до
вдома на оридло
ведмеді new збрую передавали три дні
тисячі зоні конфлікту відривали прямого в
мінську то париже одну приватний гід ось
ці формати
му мережі сепаратисти за процесом зубів
букер здобувати з пустиря чіапасе
вигляд станемо а я ніби на меншу ніш 15
кілометрів скиньте танків ми їхньому пароплаві
маму місці побажання українська сторона
тато джая танк і приматами в бойовій
готовності та ще бої видно влити а то
вже за 20 млн машину і снів перевзути
муть на своїх позиціях проти експертів
оптимістичні прогнози на їхню думку
росіян і не на ти зайнята сирією і
примирення ми за ходом
щоб знову захоче цю ситуацію на
сході України
алоіс подівся ніс-то точно хіба за
її конфлікту після битви це не збрую
калібром до 100 міліметрів на роті до
дають експерти та 2 день а оружня везли
несуть і до неї вона і розв'язуючи конфлікт
але його заморожу обстрілу з одного вибуху
завищувати листівка поголів завищуються
снайпери підвищуються до вершини хіба
дуальної групи the contact фізично
все одно музикою та pokemon новий
фізичний контакт буде і момент це
був би не може пахнути і
у нові сили а ви висновки не іноземних
століття завдання україни робота щодо ситуації
на йому слово ще одна за грози провал
адамова настей місцями вибір тих, хто шукає так
звання днр і лнр чи планово провести за
владним і правилами і ви значенням і
датою раніше називало 18 жовтня
і pc виступу так вона пісня проти збоку
україни доїсть на прямого контактного
групи в миску сепаратисти з атласу
перенести вибори на доступний рік
експертів так вчинку надвоє на їхню
думка на зепп мене москва на pidи отже
затікав іншого знання про вибір за ходом
росія буде стриманий росія до магате ми
все буде жорсткого знання цех
виборі
олаїн і думаю що все зможе позитивного
тини тайці перегони дати ламає
shemale зради ти все у нинішньому вуста не
так заводних народних республік
то мати but i release me мої дієти
політичної партії мої знову ти можеш
вивести перед вибір чую компанії вчаться
на рази можна його в публіку йому вірна
Москва настала разу когось із вибором
ще й тому що одні з догляду та розряду там
та харчування про продовження санкцій проти
росії